the extent to which Jordan is the only
one of us that they've really gone after
like this
well he's first of all he became famous
from this right this is the the battle
was wow he emerged he emerged from this
battle over the use of compelled
pronouns for various genders like the
very similar to breath 78 different
genders similar but not okay okay the
difference is Brett's position he comes
from a different place the way they were
going at him was so much more
unreasonable they were saying right away
that what he has to do is leave work
because he's white they were basically
saying a racist thing and everyone
universally acknowledges his racist
except for these super lefties who
thought that it made sense because in
their mind every white person is somehow
or another guilty of at least at the
very least using your privilege to
advance in the world at the into the
negative impact of people of color and
people of other ethnicities so they
decided that they are going to have a
day of exclusion and instead of this day
of absence having black people and
people of color stay home they were
gonna kick white people out so it became
an aggressive act instead of an act of
appreciation it became an act of
punishment or an act of exclusion and by
people that are clearly out of their
[ __ ] mind that was also part of the
problem is their their arguments are
incoherent you would see that [ __ ]
stupid president of the university
standing in front of those kids and they
told them to put his hands down because
he was threatening their you're scaring
us you're making violent gestures with
your hands so he puts his hands down and
they start laughing okay this is
nonsense now you're in little kids yet
little kids Ronnie get war the flies on
a grand scale in a state university and
it's all I mean this is a public
university right I mean they get funding
right this is all chaos nobody agrees
they got baseball bats they're looking
for him if he's coming back to the
school the kids form these vigilante
groups with
Bin's over what like who's threatening
you like what is happening but you need
weapons is that the big story there was
the non reporting what do you mean well
the New York Times Washington Post all
of these major organs NPR they didn't
report he didn't want to touch the story
well this is what this is my my big
theory here is that every outfit that
has a a grand narrative cannot report
the news that goes counter narrative so
racism by blacks against whites cannot
be reported by any outfit that believes
that racism is impossible by blacks
against whites that's such a
preposterous position the idea that
racism is exclusive to any group well
but the redefinition the redefinition
can suck a fat dick it's a stupid read
mo that's true this idea that the only
way you can be racist is if you have
power over that other group that's
nonsense every human beings act as
individuals they always have power over
each other you have power to intimidate
you have power to isolate you have power
if you what kind of using about this is
is that there is no pretense of
consistency I mean on that side of the
aisle it's like we're gonna throw out
the following 17 completely
contradictory rules and then we'll tell
you which rule is operative in any given
moment so you know I was gonna throw at
this concept of the Hilbert problems for
social justice so one of them is you
cannot understand me because my
experience is too different and you must
understand me because so important yeah
right or we are all similar enough that
any deviation from 50/50 shows you the
amount of sexism in a work force and we
are all so different that once you
include women in previously male
occupations you will see a great benefit
because of the diversity of opinion well
these are all these self contradictory
couplets right that you have to agree to
well that's the weird thing
is who assumed that I just buy all of
your stuff I think we've made a terrible
tactical error we fought these bad ideas
rather than saying maybe we should just
accept all of your bad ideas and then
show you what kind of weird
no yes no no no no you can't do that cuz
they don't make sense
you can't say oh yeah they make sense
man how do I know when you're serious
well but that if I just let those
through and those things fail but that's
my point is is that by showing the
internal this is in mathematics we call
this reductio ad absurdum that once you
take on too many different points you
show the conflicts showing that those
things can't all be true
there's no way in which if I accept all
of your ideas I can run anything